- We are back and it's
game time with Salma Hayek.
Give it up for her!
(clapping and cheering)
We just celebrated some creepy holidays
like Halloween, of course.
And since there's some
residual creepiness in the air,
it is time to play "What's
Creepin' Up On Me?"
(upbeat music)
(clapping and cheering)
♪ What's creepin' up on me ♪
- (laughing) I love you so much.
♪ What's creepin' up on me? ♪
So weird, oh, I love you.
And you're so cute that you
make it cool, it's so annoying.
You and Salma can just go
on an island away from me.
- Oh, wow.
(laughing)
- So how competitive, are you competitive?
You told me in the break
that you're, are you?
(crowd laughing)
- (laughs) Are you?
- I'm not.
I'm not that competitive,
but I love people
who are competitive.
- Okay.
You're gonna love me.
- I find it hilarious.
So I like to push their buttons.
- Okay, oh, I love it!
Push them, okay, so
we're on the same team--
- I'm gonna win.
- (laughs) Well, we're on the same team.
- Oh, okay.
- So we both lose.
- Then I am gonna win.
- Yes, yes.
(laughing)
Well, this is the good
news, this is how it works.
Salma will start with
her back to the screen.
I'll give her clues about
what's creepin' up behind her,
on the screen, without
saying the name of the thing.
So I have to describe it.
Then we're gonna switch and
Salma will give me clues.
We can pass if one is too hard.
Just say, "pass" if I'm sucking at it.
If we can correctly guess
11 things in two rounds,
the audience will win a cool prize.
Let's not let them down.
(cheering and clapping)
Okay, so ready?
Let's get in position.
- No pressure.
- Okay, so I'm giving you clues first.
Okay, so let's start the clock and go!
Oh, hoo, hoo!
- Owl!
- Yes!
(dings)
Oh. (hisses)
- Snake!
- Yes!
(dings)
Okay. (cackles)
- Witch!
- Yes!
(dings)
Oh, he's so good, "Deadpool"!
"Deadpool"?
- Oh, Ryan.
- Oh, "The Proposal," yes!
Yes, Ryan Reynolds.
(dings)
(clapping)
Ooh, oh.
Oh, this is Tex-Mex.
(stammers) Oh, how do you describe it?
- Chicken con carne!
- It's runny and you dip chips in it.
- Oh, (stammers) is it nachos?
- You dip chips in it.
Kind of, what's on nachos?
How do you say--
(stammering)
- Guacamole?
- Oh God, pass, pass, pass!
(laughing)
Oh. (buzzes)
- Fly.
- Yes!
(dings)
(talking over each other)
What, oh! (mumbles)
- Dentist.
- Yeah!
(dings)
(cheering and clapping)
Okay, and then, oh.
(exhales) And then--
- Birthday!
- Yup.
- Birthday, mordida.
(dings)
Angelina!
- Okay, okay.
(horn blares)
What did I do for dentist? (laughs)
- I don't know, but I got it.
- You got it!
We're switching.
- I'm bad but I'm psychic.
- Okay, we're switching.
(cheering)
- I'm not gonna be able to talk that fast.
You're gonna be angry at me
'cause you're competitive.
- No, I'm not gonna be angry with you.
You're Salma Hayek, I love you.
Okay, so go, let's do it.
(laughing)
- Oh, Day of the Dead.
- What, Dia de los--
(stammers)
- They're very hard, it's--
- Skeleton?
- Yes.
(cheering and clapping)
(dings)
Oh, the itsy bitsy--
- Zombie.
Spider!
- Yes.
(dings)
(clapping)
Okay, meow.
- Cat?
(laughing)
- Inside...
When you have diarrhea, you go to there.
(beeps)
(laughing)
- Yes!
(dings)
(laughing)
(clapping)
Okay, oink oink!
- Pig?
- No, that was the wrong one, I'm sorry.
Spring, spring, this animal
in spring is very popular.
- A lamb!
(laughing)
- No, it goes. (brays)
- Donkey!
- Yes.
(dings)
Oink oink?
- Okay.
(laughing)
(horn blares)
Oh, this is like--
- Oh, did we get it?
We did it, we did it!
(cheering)
(screaming)
(clapping)
- We're good!
- We are amazing.